hello everyone and welcome back to the
world fish random championship it's day
three so we are in the rapid section the
first a game of the rapid ended in a
draw and the Magnus is still losing by
nine points so he really needs to start
working on those points and well there
are only three more games left in the
RapidEye section the time format before
we go into the blood section so Wesley
now with the white pieces he goes for f4
the move we discussed in the previous
game
I wish at night the bitter end f4 are
the two candidate moves so Wesley was
for f4 nice to be stuck by Magnus
guarding the a7 phone and now nice to be
three by Wesley with d5 by Magnus and
now immediately going for efore grabbing
space in the center d captures Queen
captures and now of course it's not a
problem to bring your queen out early
into the center there's no night you
know to kick the Queen away with Knight
f6 so Knight F to d7 now preparing
Knight to f6 and now Knight e3 we have
c6 by Magnus clearing the c7 square for
the bishop and now Bishop the f2 by
Wesley with Bishop to c7 and here
already seems like a very very nice
developing move attacking the the pawn
here but it leaves the well the d7
undefended and here Wesley just was
Knight f5 and it opens up a double
attack towards both the e7 ended the g7
point so it seems a well either its
iterates a pawn wandered by Magnus or
well a deliberate pawn sacrifice for
rapid development however Magnus had the
option of Knight the d5 here and just
creating a double attack against the f4
pawn here which runs into c4 Knight
characters and now Knight captures on e7
width check King to d8 and rook to e1
we're strong for Wesley and now you
would have to find nice to e5 which is
just well it's not all that easy from
that position point being the knight is
now under attack and you cannot capture
on a4 do two night to d3 check a very
nice fork so you will just be able to
win the game here so it's not a force
line but it is okay for Magnus at the go
Knight to d5 here but okay with ecigs by
Magnus and now just give
the g-seven pawn nightcap person g7
Queen to f8 and now night back to h5
with h6 preparing Bishop to e7 which
will come with an attack on the Queen so
he will get some activity for the pawn
queen
sorry Bishop to e2 and now worship the
h7 pushing the Queen back Queen to f3
and now rook the g8 it's okay for the
pawn you've you've gotten some
development with Bishop to d3
Wesley wants to trade down the h7 Bishop
is a very strong piece Bishop the g6
Magnus's okay where we can trade but
then I want my F pawn on g6 Wesley's
still characters with Bushell characters
F captures and now Knight back to g3 and
now Magnus is able to win back the pawn
so rush of characters on f4 and now we
have a short Castle by Wesley yes this
is a short castle so also a king sized
castle so now the king is the king is
safe but on the other hand Magnus can
now start pushing his pawns and here he
does so he plays g5 Wesley not all that
impressed he goes nice - E - pushes the
bishop back and here Magnus decides that
it's not whatever we're going all out
here he pushes he 5 he traps his own
Bishop and Wesley goes for it with g3
and now just a nice queenside castle by
Magnus preparing to bring the rook into
the game we had G captors on at 4 and
now not G captures which opens up the G
file after King to H 1 it will not be
all that simple to continue the attack
we don't have any pieces going for the
attack so instead Magnus played he
captures an F or he left the opportunity
of pushing these pawns instead and maybe
opening up the position maybe if this
pawn reaches g3 so Wesley played Bishop
captures and b6 you're up material you
want to trade down with a capture some
basics and now rook b t1 saying okay I
don't mind you doing a few pawn pushes
we have nice the e5 by Magnus going
after the Queen here and now Queen back
the c3 by Wesley we have Queen to d6 and
now comes the night eat the d4 preparing
some very nasty ideas the knight can
come for example to F
and Magnus has to do something he's now
in a piece he has some of these pawns
fairly close to the White King but he
has eight minutes on the clock
whereas it Wesley has ten minutes on the
clock so he continues pushing we have g4
Knights the f5 by Wesley as planned and
now nice to f3 with check route capture
son on f3 doesn't really work because of
G characters comes with checks so you
don't have time to pick up the Queen
even though black is better a white is
better here it would be very complicated
because you have to calculate King F 1
and then rook G 1 check King captures
Queen goes here with check now your if
the King moves you're getting Queen GG
you mate so here Wesley would have to
give up the knight this way and then
after pawn captures Queen captures
captures captures rook d5 going after
Luke to h5 you would have to find a
queen to h3 check and now well after the
after the King moves you will just be
able to trade Queens with Queen 2 G 3
check and then you're just going to
enjoy your extra piece but it requires a
lot of calculation and it is not
necessary so Wesley just moves back with
King to h1 and now Queen to d7 attacking
the knight and f5 and now
Wesley finds a very intriguing idea
Knight the e7 check well not just
winning the exchange it's not really the
point as Magnus will also take the rook
on e1 but King to b8 and now Knight
captures and g8 Magnus also grabs the
rook Knight captures anyone and now
Queen to e5 with check King the a8 and
now Knight back to f6 so here
Wesley's threatening Magnus Queen and
also threatening to win a piece with
rook captures anyone so Magnus goes to
f7 with Queen to f7 and now Wesley could
grab the night here there it's it's a
perfectly fine winning move but Wesley
plays the absolute best winning move
which is rook captures on f4 and it was
on this move 29 that Magnus Carlsen
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to do here there is no defense
against rook to a a 4 mate as the Queen
covers the b8 square rather there is but
you after b5 then Wesley just picks up
the night with Queen captures night as
the rook now guards D
gars the knight here or you can play the
even flashy look to a4 check for example
pawn captures Queen a5 check will now
pick up the look with check and after
King a7 now can just go check King moves
to be 895 and you are again enjoying
your extra piece because if Queen
captures just Knight to d7 check picks
up the Queen so really just after Luke
captures a net for Magnus resigned and
we have our first ever official Fisher
random world champion Wesley so who
really earned that I believe up until
this point he won 8 matches in in his
quest for the official random World
Chess Championship title and during the
finals in the semi-finals he hasn't lost
a single game so he defeated he defeated
nepo without losing a single game and he
defeated Magnus without losing a single
game
Magnus only got one draw in the
classical times time format and one draw
in the rapid section so all the other
games was the one he won three games in
classical and now this game in in rapid
so just amazing stuff it's well it's
very interesting and it seems that nip
was doing fairly well against Caruana so
it seems that both the Wesley and and
Napo are are the the favorites when it
comes to fish random and we'll see what
happens
well we have another world of fish
random championship next year or maybe
we'll have the candidates tournament for
the official random or maybe it will
just be an open tournament with online
qualifiers or maybe it will be every two
years so we'll see how it goes but
whatever happens Wesley so is the the
first-ever official random world
official champion beating Magnus Carlsen
the reigning world champion in normal
chess by a score of 13 and a half only
two and a half that's that's just insane
so congratulations to Wesley and we'll
see where he takes it from here so
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank our golf Paul
Hurst and Josh was selling for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check too on my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon
we're gonna check out a few more games
maybe between Fabi and the neppo if
there are some
interesting games checking up on some of
the games from the European team
championship and as we haven't had a
chance to cover a lot of them due to the
world fish random championship and of
course checking up on your wonderful
suggestions while we're preparing our
next big saga so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day